三十八八代
排名在日食为热酒
擂董熊、食肥天不必
排名在海丹腾的下周
颇一供在家里面
请取着《 热衣浪之后》
颅烫进打开
准备主帜的方便
与台 设好
浓卜,感谢大家的这个
准备!
我打算了
1个中间,我是利档盛起不清
不要打开明天的
这件事就吓给我
今天我们要请阿师相
来帮我们介绍一个
非常重要的问题
为什么在冲泡
我們再充兩杯份的時候
就會變得難過了呢
我常常聽到誘導耶
對 因為大家都很想知道對不對
對呀 真的耶
所以阿智商 為什麼呢
因為只有原因
只有一個
只有一個嗎
對
太好 這樣的話
大家如果知道這個原因的話
一定很好調整過來
對
所以今天我告訴大家
那就麻煩阿智商了
OK 那開始吧
開始吧
大家好
阿拉之上
沖泡兩杯份的時候
會變難喝的原因到底是什麼呢?
我剛剛說只有一個原因
太想知道了
對
那一個的原因是
兩杯份的話
時間抽
抽時間
我們沖泡的時間會有不一樣嗎?
對 不一樣
因為之前的影片我介紹過
一杯的量大概是三分鐘三十左右
是不是?
對,大家都有參考我們的這個沖煮的時間
對,然後基本上大家覺得那兩倍分的話
時間也大概是兩倍
所以是七分鐘嗎?
對,七分鐘左右
對,如果兩倍分七分鐘左右
萃取太多了
所以萃取會變成過脆的感覺嗎?
對,過脆的感覺
所以後來的味道是太苦、太乾
口感是太乾、太硬
這些不好的味道都會跑出來的感覺
所以我現在介紹這次兩杯蔥泡的做法
所以那正確的時間也會跟我們說嗎?
對!一定正確的時間
兩杯份的完美蔥煮時間
這次兩杯份的話我建議
前杯我建議是這個
KARITA蛋糕粒杯我一樣
然後這個是比較大一點
跟我們平常用的155不一樣嗎
不一樣的155我們是這個
可以比較一下它的大小嗎
大小這樣
好可愛喔
水出來
我們剛剛下班
遊戲乾淨
遊戲乾淨的
建議是兩杯份
還是用一般比較好
如果只有帶一五的人
建議是這個最大的量
是幾克呢?
大概是二十克
最多
這樣的話二十克的話會沖到多少的量呢?大概是三60cc1.18克的話1.18克對所以呢 我就是用這個一包
好 然後呢
這次介紹前杯的兩杯的量跟深焙
那深焙的話
深焙的話這個還是Hario B60
對 阿滋商人非常推薦
深焙最好喝的
就是用兩杯我建議是02克
好
嗯 OK
前輩我們用這個台灣店也有開始賣
Papua New Guinea
這個的水洗呢
台灣也比較少耶
好的
Papu
好少見喔
對好少見
這個日本廠商的豆子呢
台灣也買得到
大家開始最近在台灣也喝得到我們京都的咖啡豆
是
前輩的話一樣
我們的Brain
那我先前輩的兩輩的量
我先告訴大家
先介紹一倍的比例
我介紹的是每一隻一樣
14克250cc
最好喝的比例
那兩倍分
一樣多比例兩倍
咖啡豆28克
那我們這樣的話要充足到幾毫呢?
充足大概是500cc
真的是剛剛好兩倍
然後時間真的是請小心一點
不用7分鐘
那一樣維持三分半嗎?
但是如果跟一杯的時間一樣的話
這樣也是我覺得是萃取不夠
所以味道會出不來的感覺
對 出不來的 對
酸度也太明顯
又變成太酸的 卡黑
所以加30秒
建議是10分鐘到10分鐘半左右結束
重完
這樣的話萃取的感覺是剛剛好嗎?
對 剛剛好 剛剛好
對
OK
然後那我
泡泡河
麻煩阿智商了
OK
開始我們水溫93度左右
好
跟一般的沖煮是一樣的水溫
一樣的一樣的
然後那個泡的做法也是我們是五段
五段
對
那這樣每一段要沖多少的水呢
那都是100
都是100塊
那先100然後攪拌
要等免煎20秒之後
200 300 400 500
那這樣剛好每次沖煮的量跟
也是兩倍
對兩倍很精準
很香
好香的味道喔
BUFF
還3秒左右
OK
到25秒開始
來
先倒200
OK
然後大概是這邊好了
一杯的時候比較下面兩杯份的話大概是這邊好了接下來倒餐盤兩杯份
出水的量可以比較大一點
所以我們用大水去注水
對
讓它有攪拌也沒有關係嗎
就混在一起的感覺
但是我覺得
總共的時間是想要四分鐘左右
所以不要一直等耶
不要一直等
不要一直等到400
之後到500cc
剛剛好
OK 那接下來煎杯
那煎杯的比例
一杯的量
一樣14顆257
那先輩的話
不用簡單兩輩的量
那這樣的話要幾顆才比較好呢
我覺得先輩的話
顆比較少
兩顆少一點
所以是
二十六顆
這樣的話用二十六顆去做充足會比較好
對,比較好
對,苦度還有甜感也是剛剛好
還有軌度也是可以出一點
前焙的時候一樣
比一般的再粗一點
粗一點
對 一點點
粗一點點
也是為了不要讓它過脆嗎
對 沒錯
對對對
所以這樣子剛剛好
這是一刀流
生焙的一刀流沖住
這次最主的時間是
3分鐘到3分鐘30左右
比前焙還要快的感覺
快的 對對對
快的感覺
OK
那開始囉
2100cc
然後攪拌不用喔
煎杯不要攪拌喔
不可以攪拌喔
對 不可以攪拌
烹起來了 烹起來
好香喔
對
可愛耶
可愛的
澎澎的
對
再回吸
那還是開始囉
那一樣呢
特別的做法
這個拉高呢
這樣
不用停喔
慢慢拉高
這樣
因為空氣跟熱水
混在一起的話
後面的口感是比較軟一點的
大家請參考一下
試試看
這樣做法
好
OK
大概是一分鐘左右
開始這邊慢慢
不要...
不要在外面
對,要在中心的感覺
對,在中心的感覺
好漂亮喔
對 漂亮的
煎白的特色耶
砰砰的
對
這樣這樣也要出來好療癒喔對療癒OK 到500喔
快要
500一刀流
流手有一點累耶
三分鐘都要一刀流
手不可以休息
OK 快要
OK
剛剛好
好
再拿金色
辛苦了
一樣 看得出來
從顏色就知道現在已經是美麗了
那千倍嗎 千倍 千倍
非常期待8倍
8倍 真的耶
兩倍分
怎麼樣
對
真的是用185
兩倍分的量去充足的話
對啊
這個甜感
甜感真的特別甜感很明顯耶
不會一次沖兩杯
一杯比較好喝
對啊
本來是兩杯份不好變不好
大家都沖兩杯變難喝
對變難喝
現在兩杯份比較好喝
真的請大家參考耶
接下來先輩
先輩怎麼樣
倒流的
對 倒流的
風味跟一杯的兩一模一樣的風味耶
顏色也很漂亮
對 很好漂亮耶
好了
太乾淨 太舒服了
對啊
真的耶
真的 真的好好喝
對
在家裡也可以沖兩杯
也可以沖這麼好喝
真的真的
這個做法請參考一下
對 非常推薦
對 推薦
阿滋桑,我們今天也要請阿滋桑來幫我們上日文小教室的課啦!
來了來了來了!
大家喜歡的嗎?
對,大家都非常期待這個小單元
是嗎?
都可以學到非常實用的日文
對呀!真的耶!真的!
好,阿滋桑,我們今天想要學的日文是
老闆,請問可以續飛嗎?
老闆可以續飛嗎?
OK,好的!
好,OK,我會學習了
不好意思,你再多一杯,你會喜歡嗎?
可愛!
再一次吧!
對不起
再一次!
最高!
請大家來京都店的咖啡的時候
跟我們有交談喔
有交談喔!
非常期待!
請大家看完這支影片
請務必在家裡試試看
好喝的兩杯份的咖啡怎麼沖煮
喜歡影片的話幫我們按讚
也要追蹤我們的頻道
也留言告訴我們你的心得喔
OK 麻煩你
一起期待下支影片
謝謝大家收看 謝謝你
掰掰